bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de municipales 2014 le rendez
vous politique de la rédaction qui vous
est dorénavant proposé chaque mardi dès
18h30 en direct et ce jusqu'à la fin du
mois de mars alors ce soir je recevrai
deux personnalités politiques tout
d'abord ismaïl un bon soir non seulement
candidat investi par le parti socialiste
amour pas et puis en quelques minutes je
recevrai également bernard de bain le
maire sortant ump de saint-cyr l'école
qui donc nous rejoindra en deuxième
partie d'émission dans ces deux villes
je pourrais dire c'est peut-être un peu
populaire de dire ça il ya quand même du
pain sur la planche dernière ce que vous
en pensez parce qu'il ya quand même de
nombreuses listes alors vous il se met
la femme que vous êtes investie par le
parti socialiste donc je d'édition sur
maurepas vous avez été choisi par les
militants le 10 octobre dernier mais le
maire sortant georges mougeot a annoncé
qu'il ne se représenterait pas et du
coup ça attise quand même beaucoup l'est
les appétits puisqu'il ya beaucoup de
candidats qui sont déclarés outre vous
il ya aussi michel sapin l'adjoint aux
finances qui était lui aux côtés de
georges mougeot depuis 89 pire le
guérinel quel est le premier adjoint lui
étudie grégory galeriste est investi par
l'ump michel haeck et adjoint au sport
sans étiquette jean sindou faurie
conseiller municipal d'opposition et
puis j'ai envie d'être le petit dernier
le dernier en tout cas des candidats
déclarés nagy de bâches pour debout la
république
en 2008 il y avait déjà quatre listes et
puis il y avait un deuxième tour qui
avait été emporté par journaux jouent
avec 54% des voix voilà c'est pour
rappeler un peu le contexte est ce que
parmi tous ces candidats il ya un
adversaire que vous craignez plus que
d'autres l'objectif de notre candidature
l'objectif est d'abord un objectif on se
présente c'est pour des raisons
particulières et nous on est candidat
quand je dis nous mois à travers le
parti socialiste et ceux qui ont rejoint
le parti socialiste parce que ce n'est
pas que le parti socialiste qui fait qui
va tout seul aux élections municipales
nous allons avec d'autres partenaires et
on en parlera tout à l'heure mais en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que nous
on monte une liste pour donner une offre
politique à cette ville quand même temps
des projets on a une ambition pour cette
ville d'ailleurs c'est le slogan de
notre de notre liste et c'est cela qui
est d'abord important c'est répondre aux
besoins démord pas bien ensuite vous
m'interrogez sur le fait qu'ils aient
beaucoup de listes la province la
première des choses c'est que c'est la
démocratie chacun a droit d'être
candidats donc là dessus j'ai rien à en
dire par contre ce qu'on peut constater
c'est que la multitude de candidatures
est dû au fait que la majorité actuelle
a éclaté si elle n'aurait pas éclaté
certainement le nombre de candidats
auraient été moins nombreux comme vous
l'avez dit le maire sort le maire ne se
représente pas trois candidats issus de
sa majorité son candidat s'il y a trop
de candidats c'est peut-être de ce côté
là qu'il faudrait aller chercher
l'adversaire politique dans ces
candidats vous regarde avec plus
d'attention je pense notamment à michel
chappard peut-être qui est élu depuis 89
aux côtés de georges mougeot qui a été
adoubé en plus par le maire sortant
parce que c'est quelqu'un que vous
regardez en particulier
comme je voulais dit si c'est une
manière de perception
on voit peut-être pas les choses de la
même manière
nous ce qu'on veut c'est s'adresser aux
morts pas bien tout le reste et tout ce
qui est périphérique je ne dis pas que
ça nous intéresse pas c'est important de
savoir ce qu'est les adversaires ont
dans leur programme ont dans leur idée
même si on on sait à peu près les lignes
directrices de chacun des candidats ce
qui importe pour nous c'est d'être sur
les starting blocks on a travaillé
pendant un certain nombre de mois déjà
avec les la liste on est prêt pour
proposer un projet au mort d'asia pour
nous c'est ce qui compte tout le reste
je dirais chacun vaque à ses occupations
liste est prête à un autre qui step
reste alors le rêve ou est ce qu'elle
est ouverte parce que du coup alors vous
imposez pas ma question et vous peur de
vos adversaires d'accord
mais je veux me situer sur l'essentiel
qui n'est pas de me poser des questions
sur mes adversaires qu est ce qu ils
pensent qu'elles qu'est ce qu'ils font
mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
réveiller leur patient aux
problématiques des morlaisiens il ya des
enjeux très attention quand même vous
posez du coup est manqué qui viennent
par là mais est-ce qu'elle les accords
aujourd'hui possible
je pense notamment jean sindou faurie
par exemple candidat vert est ce qu'il
ya des accords avec certains des
candidats qui sont possibles on peut pas
avoir un accord avec quelqu'un qui est
déjà candidat quel qu'il soit est ce
qu'il ya des discussions dans ces cas là
au soir du premier tour on verra les
discussions et les alliances possibles
aujourd'hui le parti socialiste je vous
l'avais dit la dr je vous avais fait un
petit scoop entre guillemets c'est que
le parti socialiste ne part pas seule à
cette élection puisqu'il part avec le
parti communiste donc déjà là ce sont d
accord mais des accords de premier tour
et des accords programmatiques c'est à
dire qu'il s'agit pas de se mettre en
paix steve explosions juste trop discuté
entre des candidats qui se déclare
candidat et il peut y avoir des accords
s'ils souhaitent présenter une liste aux
cas ce qui est sûr madame c'est qu'il ya
des affinités avec quelques listes
ensuite nous on a un projet ceux qui
trouvent notre projet séduisant parce
qu'il est séduisant et qui veulent nous
rejoindre autour de notre projet ils
sont bienvenues mais à dire la vérité
aujourd'hui je ne vais pas ce soir sur
aujourd'hui chacun s'est déclaré les
candidats dont vous avez parlé ceux
issus de la majorité se sont déclarés
donc après à partir de là chacun var en
campagne se présente devant les morts
pas elle-même eurasien jugeront ce qui
est important pour nous c'est que nous
allons nous allons de je dirais
solidaire avec le parti communiste aux
élections municipales et petit scoop
d'autres viendront aussi d'accord et
d'autre c'est très bien vinet mais dans
les jours à venir de vos mains vitré je
vous expliquerai lesquels mais voulait
pas me dire ça maintenant pour vous dire
la vérité c'est que aux autres c'est
sévère on était en discussion très
longtemps avec le parti communiste et là
c'est ça qui est important c'est que
c'est des discussions programmatiques
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire comment on le
fait sur quoi on est d'accord c'est ça
l'essentiel qu'est ce qu'on offre aux
morts casier sur l'intercommunalité
l'emploi le logement on a travaillé
maintenant vous ouvre une deuxième phase
cette première phase est terminée nous
allons ensemble à l'élection une
deuxième phase va s'ouvrir avec
les écologistes europe ecologie les
verts une phase de discussion qui sera
de même nature je pense programmatique
et si nous avons un projet sur lequel
nous pouvons nous retrouver en tout cas
où l'ossature est
ce qu on a déjà produit avec l'ensemble
de la liste je dirais les discussions
ouvertes sont ouvertes voilà après sur
ceux qui se sont déclarés on verra au
soir du premier tour d'accord et votre
liste on a signé les constituer
pratiquement la liste est quasiment
constitué donc là on a une ouverture
comme je vous le dis avec le parti
communiste on a encore quelques encore
de la place pour europe ecologie les
verts si on arrive à conclure un accord
seul cela va se décider dans les
quelques jours qui viennent on va
maintenant parler du camp même du
programme quasi les sens mais les
premières pistes de la politique aussi
intéressant sur une commune je rappelle
aussi que vous avez été élu conseiller
général du canton en 2008 quand on vous
avait ravi à l'ump henri pas lieu à
l'occasion d'une triangulaire alors là
évidemment comme il ya beaucoup de
candidats ya peut-être aussi voilà c'est
peut-être une façon aussi prendre une
mairie avec plusieurs candidats ça ouvre
aussi plusieurs possibilités en tout cas
je je je vois ce qui vous intéresse
c'est de céder à faire le mort d'asia de
personnes etc
c'est normal je comprends mais moi ce
dont je souhaite qu'on parle c'est du
projet parce qu'on a nous des axes de
campagne sont assez forts
sur lesquels on a des réponses sur le
logement l'emploi la démocratie
participative alors je pense que ça
c'est intéressant était mort passe bien
et après comme je vous l'aï dit tout à
l'heure nous not least c'est une liste
je suis conseiller général comme vous
l'avez dit du canton ne mord pas le
parti communiste avec nous nous
connaissons très bien le territoire et
nous pensons amener des solutions de me
reposer là c'est ça qui est qui est
important alors on va parler du
programme ça y est on y vient l'emploi
vous avez dit c'est une de vos priorités
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire quand on est
maire pour l'emploi lorsqu'on est plutôt
une prérogative d'état
lorsqu'on les met dans une commune je
crois ce qu'il faut avant tout ses
avoirs dans sa commune un dynamisme
économique une commune vi parce que il
ya que les activités royales et
dynamisme économique on ne peut pas le
nier comme moi mais on peut le renforcer
et c'est pas parce qu'il existe déjà
qu'il est ce qu'on doit s'en satisfaire
on peut faire mieux et je vous
rappellerai juste
un exemple baxter qui nous gros société
sur maurepas kit marpa
et lorsqu'on le dynamisme économique on
pense tout de suite le fait qu'ils aient
beaucoup de magasins de chaussures j'ai
rien contre 1 beaucoup de magasins de
vêtements tout ce qui est commercial on
pense que c'est du dynamisme économique
je le pense aussi mais on peut aussi
imaginer que le dynamisme économique
peut être diversifiée par exemple
il peut avoir des grosses entreprises
qui sont le genre de baxter
puisque baxter est parti sur saint
quentin en yvelines ça veut dire que une
agglomération comme ça quand on line
peut apporter plus en termes
d'imposition par exemple moi je pense
que il y à un dynamisme économique il
faut qu'il y ait un territoire qui soit
propice à ce que les entreprises
viennent et reste
sur les infrastructures routières de
transport sur
les engagements que peut faire une
commune et son volontarisme pour attirer
les entreprises et
les moyens de communication qu'elle
qu'elle peut offrir et aussi sa capacité
à finalement à faire vivre tout un
ensemble de structures d'entreprises qui
entrent elles peuvent créer un dynamisme
et un bassin propice donc ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose il faut
donner une réponse aux habitants c'est
ça aussi qui est important quand on est
un mort pas et qu'on veut créer son
entreprise comment on fait c'est le
parcours du combattant
tant d'autres villes aussi mais on peut
moi je réfléchis pour maurepas et pour
les marques asia on peut imaginer et
c'est une des souliers propositions que
nous on fait un guichet unique pour les
entreprises et pour les créateurs
d'entreprise vous voulez créer une
entreprise vous habitez mord pas au lieu
de faire le parcours du combattant entre
le la chambre de commerce le conseil
régional le conseil général et cetera et
cetera par des subventions dont la
mairie avoir un titre un guichet unique
à la mairie avec quelqu'un de compétent
qui peut vous répondre à toutes vos
questions ou vous aiguiller c'est une
solution pour les morlaisiens concrètes
par exemple d'accord un autre thème
rapidement le logement c'est une de vos
priorités et à pour quand même alors
pareil soutien beaucoup de mouvements -
maurepas
il ya beaucoup de logements mais une des
choses qui est qui nous importe nous
c'est que maurepas est une ville dans
laquelle moi je suis heureux de vivre et
dans laquelle les morts pas à son hôte
vivre ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'il y a des acquis sur lesquels il ne
faut pas toucher ce sont des
incompressibles je pense à notre espace
je dirais boisé qui est extraordinaire à
maurepas sur lequel il faut laisser
cet élément là parce qu'il est important
d'avoir des zones de respiration on a
autour du village aussi je dirais un
côté un peu cartes postales qui est très
agréable il faut le garder malgré tout
lorsque vous avez été à maurepas vous
avez des enfants et qui souhaitent ses
enfants à un moment donné trouver un
logement ils n'ont quelquefois d'autre
solution que de partir soit parce que
c'est trop cher soit parce qu'il ya pas
il n'y a pas d'offre et donc du coup
toute la problématique est là c'est de
permettre aux enfants de maurepas de
pouvoir rester dans la commune qu'ils
aiment en leur offrant des solutions de
logement et en même temps
gardez finalement une force vive dans
nos repas je vous rappellerai et vous le
savez certainement que la population à
maurepas ces dernières années ab c'est
tout un ensemble de jeunes donc il faut
construire mais peut-être d'autres types
de logements il faut trouver une offre
résidentielle pour ses habitants là tout
en préservant le cadre de et dernière
question votre opposition sur
l'intercommunalité actuellement maurepas
fait partie de la communauté de communes
des étangs vous vous êtes quoi plutôt
favorable à saint quentin en yvelines je
l'aï jamais caché j'ai toujours été
favorable à saint quentin en yvelines là
il y à un raté dans le sens où le bassin
de vie naturel de maurepas ses 50 ans en
yvelines tout à l'heure on parlait de
dynamisme économique le dynamisme
économique pour maurepas c'est saint
quentin en yvelines mais moi en tant que
conseil général j'ai milité pour que
leurs parents dans saint quentin en
yvelines je les dis partout c'est un
secret de polichinelle
là le fait que maurepas n'est pas ne
soit pas dans la 550 en yvelines est dû
à des problèmes je dirais entre
guillemets de personnes et non pas des
problèmes programmatique je le regrette
c'est pas une critique c'est un constat
donc aujourd'hui on est dans la
communauté des étangs c'est un fait on
fait avec parce qu'on respecte la loi
malgré tout rien nous empêche de
discuter avec ce bassin de vie qu'elle
saint quentin en yvelines pour avoir des
projets de coopération merci aux comptes
charisma evans d'être venu sur le
plateau de municipales 2014 je rappelle
vous êtes candidat pour le parti
socialiste avec le parti communiste aux
municipales à maurepas et avant de notre
site et je vous écoute et maintenant on
agit de bâches il est candidat c'est le
dernier qu'on dit a déclaré riad debout
la république
alors je m'engage parce que je suis la
différence
la différence parce je suis mort aux
patients parce que je n'accepte pas
qu'il y ait déjà trop de conflits de
notre ville alors que nous avons
beaucoup de choses à faire pour la ville
pour les mort aux patients et non pas
pour son identité personnelle pour le
siège qu'on va occuper l'autre point
numéro 1 déjà à donner la parole au
peuple utiliser le référendum du général
de gaulle étant donné que j'y suis de
nature gaulliste et de droite
républicaine un exemple tout bête
avoir une salle de prière pour les
musulmans pourquoi faire une guerre
entre les juifs les arabes les musées et
les chrétiens enfin les musulmans et les
chrétiens alors qu'il suffirait de
demander au peuple est ce que vous êtes
d'accord comme et une salle de prière à
ce peuple voilà c'est le peuple qui paye
la ville d'agde en deuil où son avis un
exemple tout bête les handicapés par
exemple ce kimono moment mon nom mon
cheval de bataille les handicapés
cancale la neige ils n'ont pas les
moyens de sortir pourquoi parce que soit
il n'y a pas assez de sel dans la ville
c'est incohérent donc il faut changer
tout ça ça c'est la différence c'est ma
différence c'est la différence que
j'incarne
et municipales 2014 se poursuit avec
l'annoncé officielle de candidature de
véronique côté millard la maire sortante
unis aient des clayes-sous-bois léonie
côté milliards qui brigue un troisième
mandat elle était d'ailleurs l'invité du
7-8 actif une écoute
je repars pour un mandat de six ans
après avoir à la fois mûrement réfléchi
parce que c'est un engagement et qui
aussi a n'est pas sans conséquence sur
la vie personnelle et familiale donc
fallait qu'elle souhaite accepter et
parce que j'ai été aussi largement
encouragée par des citoyens qui
souhaitent me soutenir voir s'investir
donc avec une équipe qui sera en
renouveler 50%
et on continue les missions avec bernard
de bain bonsoir bonjour vous êtes le
maire sortant de saint cyr l'école maire
ump vous avez été élu une première fois
en 2006 à la suite de la démission de
philippe lavaud en 2008 vous avez été
réélu dès le premier tour avec 52 56%
des voix et pourtant il y avait trois
listes en présence à l'époque votre
majorité disposait de 25 élus alors
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire que la
donne a quand même un peu changé puisque
votre conseil municipal de votre conseil
municipal 17 sont de votre majorité et
16 de votre opposition la première
question que j'ai envie de poser quand
on regarde comme ça de l'extérieur
le conseil municipal de saint cyr
l'école on se dit qu'il ya eu beaucoup
de mouvement en six ans comment vous
expliquer ces départs de cette
dispersion sein de votre équipe ces
départs je voudrais vous rappeler que
quand je suis arrivée au conseil
municipal en juin 2006 nous étions aussi
17 trous c'est une
situation qui reconnaît
pour certaines raisons
je ne m'étendrai pas sur
le départ de certains la suite entre
autres de la démission que j'avais
demandé un adjoint et de mon refus aussi
il ya quelques mois et je l'avais
exprimer ici de prendre philippe lavaud
dans ma nouvelle équipe donc je sais
qu'un un certain que ce sont les 13ème
et de l'ancien maire voilà rien fait qui
était très attaché à lui
quant à quant aux premiers qui sont
partis je dois dire que j'ai été très
déçu lorsque deux jours après le
dimanche de l'élection hassen qu'ils
étaient venus me voir dans mon bureau en
me demandant des places et des postes
que je n'avais pas prévu de leur donner
puisque je pensais qu'il fallait quand
même qu'ils apprennent un peu ce que
c'était que d'être conseiller municipal
et pour moi on vient pour servir on
vient pas pour se servir
et très rapidement ils sont partis parce
qu'ils estimaient qu'il n'avait pas les
postes qu'il leur revenait je rappelle
que vous êtes combien il ya aussi
d'autres candidats qui se sont prononcés
comme daniel garçons etienne erasmus
jean-yves maximillian gaitan desjardins
et comment on mène justement campagne
aujourd'hui quand on en croise sur le
terrain ce qu'on était vos amis d'hier
je pense notamment à guy thème des
jardins
madame desjardins n'a jamais été avec
moi
puisque c'est elle qui entre autres
étaient à l'origine du départ de
philippe laboup donc le maire précédent
j'aurais bien souhaité plusieurs fois
j'avais déjà fait des démarches que nous
nous retrouvions ça ne s'est pas fait on
ne sait jamais ce que donnera l'avenir
c'est à dire que vous êtes en
pourparlers actuellement non pas devant
nous discutions pas du tout mes jeux de
l'avenir c'est parce que déjà exprimé le
fait que si jamais je n'étais pas élu au
premier tour et qu' il y avait des
possibilités de faire des listes
communes je n'étais pas totalement
opposé à ce que nous puissions discuter
en discuter notamment et gaitan
desjardins doit la dca étonne des gens
d'un accord mais pas dès le premier tour
ça c'est pas fait pour tout j'ai un
certain nombre d'adjoints qui dans les
mois voire les années passées ont tendu
la pêche alors en tout cas si vous
souhaitez un rapprochement gaitan
desjardins sûrement vous ne souhaitez
pas le rapprochement avec des garçons ça
roule l'a bien compris puisque vous avez
un litige avec avec lui en ce moment
puisque vous poursuit vous me l'avez
poursuivi pour diffamation ainsi que
l'association anticor alors c'était au
sujet d'une enquête d'opinion vous aviez
fait réalisé et publié dans les colonnes
du journal municipal dont on va
découvrir ici quelques et quelques
exemplaires vous l'a regretté d'avoir
cette enquête d'opinion non pas du tout
on vous accuse d'avoir financé d'avoir
fait financer par la mairie côté des
sondages regarder dans la vie politique
actuelle il ya main il y en a tout le
temps il a été fait plus d'un an avant
la date limite du 1er mars et un sondage
je vous le rappelle c'est
un instant t qu'on a un réseau mars
était plus jeune âge lui assure
qu'aujourd'hui on aurait le même
résultat ne serait ce que parce que la
politique nationale a peut être
influencé aussi et puis ce qui s'est
passé depuis un an dans la ville ne
prouve que on continue à avancer alors
daniel garçons à saisir en quoi la
république puisqu'il a estimé que ce
sondage n'aurait pas dû être financé ma
vie qu'est ce que vous lui répondez à
des milliards sont mais je lui ai dit et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que j'ai porté
plainte
puisque j'estimais qu'on avait atteint
mon honneur et mon intégrité j'ai
toujours dit que quand j'étais à la
mairie je ne me servirai pas de la
mairie j'ai rappelé que lorsque je me
déplaçais c'est avec ma voiture ce n'est
pas de voiture je les vends du g10 que
lorsque j'avais fait des voyages que ce
soit les trois voyages en allemagne le
voyage en écosse le voyage les trois
voyages que les faits au portugal j'ai
toujours payé moi même y compris les
hôtels les déplacements
dont que je pense que connaissant daniel
garçons parce que je sais que lui même
est un petit peu embêté par cette
affaire il aurait peut-être mieux valu
qu'ils me passe un coup de téléphone
pour demander avant d'écrire au
procureur de la république des
explications d'accord mais moi aussi
j'aurais aimé aussi que vous appelez
afin que les maps à jouer même pas les
salons m'attire c'est un rendez vous en
rendez vous ratés on va parler
maintenant les des priorités pour pour
saint cyr l'école dans vos dossiers dans
les priorités qui sont les vôtres
l'urbanisme notamment est ce que c'est
une priorité parce qu'on al'impression
leurs forces pour construire sa vie
alors attendez je vois partout des
affiches ou des tracts dans lequel on
manque que bétonnage le quesnoy en
france il ya aussi
plan
d'urbanisme qui vient de la part du
conseil régional qui pousse les communes
à bâtir de plus en plus il y avait un
objectif du gouvernement était de 500
usines en vous votre mission - je ne
tenais pas cruel ce n'est pas la ville
qui bâtit lorsque vous avez un
constructeur qui achètent de trois
maisons pour réunir si jamais elle paie
lui l'autorisent à le faire on ne peut
pas l'empêcher g dans la zone la plus
dense de la ville il ya trois ans déjà
descendu la hauteur maximum de 15 m à 12
m donc en fait un étage 2 - construire
justement pour ralentir ce genre de
choses mais il arrive un moment où on
peut pas descendre en dessous dès demain
la zac renard 1400 logements
quand vous regardez
la zac qui a été fait en 2000 entre 2004
et 2006 la zac de l'abbaye elle est très
verte beaucoup d espaces verts et bien
la zac renard sera encore moins dense
avec encore plus d espaces verts je
rappelle que ce terrain ne nous
appartenait pas ils appartenaient au
ministère de la défense est à dire aux
services des domaines et que si la ville
n'était pas intervenu pour trouver un
aménageur le ministère la défense
l'aurait vendu à des promoteurs et avec
des promoteurs nous n'aurions pas eu
notre mot à dire autre autres thèmes de
campagne en tout cas ça ça l'école qui
va être abordée je pense et les
transports sacyr est une ville très
encombrée par les voitures qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire quand on est candidat
est ce qu on a un programme là dessus à
la presse qu qu'est ce qu'on a fait
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire on a une
ville effectivement qui est un peu
coincé avec ce parc du château de
versailles cette colline et ses deux
voies de chemin de fer avec 3
départemental qui se croisent en un seul
point et voudriez faire tes sms la
56 % de trafic de gens qui ne font que
traverser qui viennent d'ailleurs toutes
les enquêtes l'ont montré alors qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire eh bien nous avons
en prévision un contournement nord dont
on se servira de la zac run ajustements
pour le réaliser et aussi en accord avec
le conseil général et la ville de
versailles un contournement à l'est la
route l'air 17 qui va vers bailly qui
sera déviée donc ça sera déjà dans les
trajets des projets merci beaucoup
bernard demain d'être
maire sortant de saint cyr l'école
candidat pour l'ump cette émission est
maintenant terminée nouvelle émission
vous le savez c'est dans une semaine
elle vous sera présentée par frenchy
bonne soirée et à bientôt